I'm Alexei Pushkov professor of
international relations and TV anchor
from Moscow Russia I was moderator of
the central asian session I think the
session was a success which was in large
part due to the participation of mrs.
Rosa otunba the president of Kyrgyzstan
who delivered a very passionate and
interesting speech at the same time on
the development of Kyrgyzstan which
experienced in the last five years to
popular revolts which resulted in the
ousting of the Acting President so it's
a country with a very dramatic recent
development which has now overcome those
troubles and has become a democratic
parliamentary republic which is a
political success in this area the
speakers from Kyrgyzstan and
Turkmenistan have brought the positions
of their governments on the economic and
social strategies both countries are
rather successful in their economic
development kazakhstan displays about
nine ten percent of GDP growth per year
and Turkmenistan hopes to go to the
level of fifteen percent of GDP in 2011
so there's a two story of economic
success and they can be called probably
by regional standards at least as
economic miracles and all the other
participants brought their own views on
the challenges of the area especially
pmol the representative of the European
Union Central Asia who
basically formulated three areas where
the fate of the region will be decided
its regional cooperation it's the
security security dimension and also the
fight against drugs which are which are
undermining very much the the the
prospects of this area and making is
more fragile as I said I think it was a
success we didn't talk so much about
innovation I think we spoke about the
general outlines of the future
development of the region maybe
innovation is something which becomes a
priority in conditions of stability this
area is not yet an area which can both
high level of stability some countries
of this area are in the state of
transition some are still austerity
areas which have not even started a
transition to a more democratic
political regime so I think that what is
more important for Central Asia is
economic development is social stability
and a political transition to modem
cratic forms of development of course
there is innovation but probably the
representatives of the government's
which were present there they did not
stress the elements of innovation in
their development for there are as they
sink more important priorities for their
countries